SERVE IN GOVERNMENT AFTER
WATCHING WHAT HE HAD TO ENDURE
TODAY, ALL POLITICS.
ALSO AT TODAY’S HEARING, NETTY
JERRY NADLER CAUGHT AGAIN
SPREADING MORE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION
ACTUALLY CLAIMING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WERE FUELING
MORE VIOLENCE AS A CAMPAIGN
STRATEGY.
CRAZY ALERT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU REALLY CAN’T HIDE BEHIND
LEGAL FICTION THIS TIME,
MR. BARR.
IT’S ALL OUT IN THE OPEN WHERE
PEOPLE CAN SEE WHAT YOU ARE
DOING FOR THEMSELVES.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS FOOTAGE FOR
HIS CAMPAIGN ADS, AND YOU APPEAR
TO BE SERVING IT UP TO HIM AS
ORDERED.
IN MOST OF THESE CITIES, THEIR
PROTESTS HAVE BEGUN TO WIND DOWN
BEFORE YOU MARCHED IN AND
CONFRONTED THE PROTESTERS.
HE DID IT HERE IN WASHINGTON,
YOU DID IN LAFAYETTE SQUARE, YOU
EXPANDED TO PORTLAND, AND NOW
YOU ARE PROJECTING FEAR AND
VIOLENCE NATIONWIDE.
IN PURSUIT OF OBVIOUS POLITICAL
OBJECTIVES.
SHAME ON YOU, MR. BARR.
>> Sean: SHAME ON YOU YOU
LIAR, CONSPIRACY THEORIST
JERRY NADLER.
HERE WITH REACTION, FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
TREY GOWDY.
THE TALKING POINTS WERE ALL THE
SAME, I WOULD CALL YOUR
CONGRESSMAN, BUT IT’S AN INSULT
AT THIS POINT AFTER TODAY’S
SHOW, BUT I AM WATCHING IT
TODAY, THEY ALL REGURGITATE AT
THE SAME LINE.
YOU ARE DOING THIS, THERE IS NO
VIOLENCE, THAT’S A LIE.
DO ALL THESE OVER 1500 POLICE
OFFICERS INJURED AND MANY MORE,
SOME BLINDED NOW I THINK WE ARE
UP TO 16 DEAD, ARE MY EYES
DECEIVING ME, TREY GOWDY?
>> OF POLITICS IS ABOUT
CONTRAST, WE HAVE CONTRAST FOR
NOVEMBER.
DO YOU WANT THE ANARCHY THAT YOU
SEE IN PORTLAND AND SEATTLE OR
DO YOU WANT A COUNTRY WHERE
EVERYONE IS SAFE AND SECURE?
WHAT YOU ALSO SAW TODAY IS WHAT
A SERIOUS GROWN-UP
ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN DO FOR THIS
COUNTRY, AND IT MAKES ME WISH
AND WONDER WHERE WE WOULD BE IF
HE HAD BEEN THE AG FROM DAY ONE.
BILL BARR HAD BEEN THE
PRESIDENT’S FIRST AG.
AND AS FOR CRAZY UNCLE JERRY,
NOW YOU KNOW WHY THE DEMOCRATS
KEPT HIM HIDDEN IN THE ATTIC
DURING IMPEACHMENT.
THEY DIDN’T WANT HIM ANYWHERE
NEAR IMPEACHMENT AND FOR ANYONE
WHO WANDERED BY THE CHAIRMAN OF
JUDICIARY HAD NO ROLE IN
IMPEACHMENT, TODAY YOU FIGURED
IT OUT.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
HE ACTUALLY SAID THE IDEA THAT
THIS IS VIOLENCE IN THE CITIES
IS A MYTH.
CLAIMING THEN YOU HAVE ALL THESE
LIBERAL DEMOCRATIC MAYORS THAT
HAVE DESTROYED THEIR CITIES BOTH
IN TERMS OF SAFETY AND SECURITY,
THEIR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS ARE
THE WORST IN THE WORLD, AND THEY
ARE OUT THERE SPREADING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT 100
FEDERAL AGENTS IN MOST CASES
PROTECTING FEDERAL PROPERTY IN
FEDERAL COURT HOUSES THAT
SOMEHOW THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE VIOLENCE FOR EXAMPLE THAT
HAS BEEN GOING ON IN PORTLAND
AND SEATTLE FOREVER, SIX
STRAIGHT WEEKS, ALMOST TWO
MONTHS NOW AND PORTLAND.
NOT DONALD TRUMP’S FAULT.
THEY REJECT HIS HELP, BUT HE
DOES HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
PROTECT FEDERAL PROPERTY, AND
THEY ARE DOING THAT JOB, AND
THEY ARE BEING INJURED AND
BLINDED AS A RESULT.
>> IT’S IS NUMBER ONE
OBLIGATION.
THE NUMBER ONE OBLIGATION OF
GOVERNMENT AS PUBLIC SAFETY.
WHAT I WISH NADLER WOULD DO IS
GO FIND ALL OF THE HOMICIDE
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
IN NEW YORK.
FIND THE PARENTS OF THAT
1-YEAR-OLD THAT GOT KILLED AND
TELL THEM THE VIOLENCE IS
MANUFACTURED.
GO FIND ALL THE HOMICIDE VICTIMS
IN YOUR OWN BACKYARD AND TELL
THEM THAT THE VIOLENCE IS
MANUFACTURED.
>> Sean: WITH ALL WE NOW KNOW
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS OUT IN THE
PUBLIC, HILLARY CLINTON’S
ESPIONAGE ACT THAT I BELIEVE 18
USC 793, THE DELETED EMAILS,
PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON THE FISA
COURT, ABUSE OF POWER,
CORRUPTION BY THE SEVENTH FLOOR
OF THE FBI, ALL THE NAMES WE’VE
OFTEN DISCUSSED, DO YOU HAVE
TREY GOWDY ANY DOUBT THAT THEY
ABUSE THEIR POWER, THAT THEY HAD
PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON THE FISA
COURT, AND THAT THEY SOUGHT TO
IMPACT AN ELECTION AND TAKE DOWN
A DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT?
BECAUSE I HAVE NO DOUBT, AND I’M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY DURHAM
HAS TAKEN SO LONG AT THIS POINT.
>> I HAVE NO DOUBT.
I WOULD SAY TWO THINGS.
YOU MENTIONED HOROWITZ TWICE.
I HOPE YOUR VIEWERS ARE
WONDERING WHY THE CHAIRMAN OF
JUDICIARY HAS NEVER CALLED
MICHAEL HOROWITZ AS A WITNESS.
HOROWITZ FOUND MISCONDUCT AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT TOO.
IT’S CALLED THE FBI.
WHY HAS THE CHAIRMAN OF
JUDICIARY NOT CALLED
MICHAEL HOROWITZ FOR THE PAST
YEAR AND A HALF?
POINT NUMBER TWO, I HOPE JOHN
DURHAM ISSUES HIS REPORT, AND I
HOPE IT’S FAIR AND EFFECT
CENTRIC BUT WE DON’T NEED JOHN
DURHAM TO KNOW WHAT’S ON THE
BALLOT IN NOVEMBER.
I DON’T NEED JOHN DURHAM TO
CONVINCE ME THAT THE FBI DIDN’T
MEET ANY OF OUR EXPECTATIONS.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU LIE TO THE
COURT WHEN YOU WERE TOLD THAT
THE EVIDENCE IS UNVERIFIABLE
SAYS AT THE TOP OF THE FISA
WARRANT, HOW DO YOU GET AWAY
WITH THAT?
>> I HOPE YOU DO NOT.
I HOPE JOHN DURHAM WILL PROVE
THAT LADY JUSTICE IS
BLINDFOLDED.
LET’S BE PATIENT, JUSTICE IS